hello everybody my name is markiplier
and I'm a little bit sick but don't let
that worry you because I'm not gonna let
it stop me
I'm literally hopped up on cold medicine
as I usually do when I play when I'm
sick and O's I was talking with yamimash
and he said oh gosh diddly Tosh more
names your mate
markiplier you should play this all game
that's bad and I asked him if it was bad
as in good or so bad that it was scary
I said no pretty much bud so I said
who's gonna play Kurt so here we are and
welcome to courage oh my god I got the
volume like way turned up on my I'm
sorry I'm late halfway through this my
voice just goes I am bread and the fact
that I was sick whoa this sensitivity is
way too high okay hey my name is Marcus
top secret laboratory what they develop
the serum code to fear some sort of a
biological weapon the ones inhale your
brain will start to scare you like
Batman I think you see scary's - your
eyes are just deceiving you
okay fighting you stole this whole
building is filled with the serum huh I
must get out of here right now for the
whole cinema fix your butt okay take
care
dr. Corey okay so yeah have the courage
to beat the fear that's why the name of
the game is courage oh good I'm so glad
to be sir american-built mattresses they
really did this guy good he's a typical
American doesn't need comfort only needs
patriotism okay I'm ready
come on the fear affect me why am i
breathing heavy alright okay I get it
ah this is what you mean - it
hi I'm gonna go towards the voice that's
left that's actually a little bit creepy
hello any more jump scares gonna pop out
of me
ironically I hope I hope that everything
is gonna come jumping out of me all once
this I'm ready for it
I've played only a few games while I was
sick cuz I haven't been take all that
often but every time I have it's been
just a little bit of a strange
experience because part of me is just
like I want to do this but at the same
time I'm like hey I'm actually having
more fun than I usually would so why not
okay I actually don't know where I'm
going so it's a little dark and I know
he only said that I needed to escape the
facility but I'm just gonna operate
under the assumption that there's gonna
be other things that I need to do before
I do that lobby good thing there's a big
old sign there hello my name is
markiplier I'm here to be scared
yamimash was saying is that this game
was so full of jump scares that he
couldn't walk two steps that's what I
was thinking anyway maybe I maybe I just
imagined this conversation okay ladies
wanted a hug lady why to thrust her hips
at me and give me a big old hug
wait was there no point coming in this
room I'm ready for whatever yup were
these oh I find that so funny right
after I get spooked
I get spooked startled thats poop stuck
not poop startled spook startled it's
too spoopy for me or the door go ernest
this could be one at every doorframe
Megna walking everyone what how do I
find that funny now I got like I got
like a permanent smile on my face now
this is really silly by the same time
it's kind of charming you know I bet
someone worked really hard and like
perfectly planned all these scares and
orchestrated them in such a way that he
knew that the pants would just fly off
of the people that he was trying to get
to watch this okay so that was the
research wing that was researching the
jump scares over thrown away all the
quarters is where all the people are I
imagine no are these American bands good
their American pets I wouldn't want any
communist beds trying to scare me
just a rock tied up in a burlap okay
right you mess up my American joke you
messed up my joke I'll never forgive you
oh hi Wow I didn't even notice you there
oh man these are loud I gotta admit but
it's that same typical jump scares on
that I've seen I've heard in every
single any horror game I've ever played
being out of it it's pretty fun kind of
for me anyway I'm having a great time
okay left wing bulbs electrical wires
generators all room just for wires oh
yes
the right wing it lists on the side that
there's a hidden room oh my god
Oh super secret wouldn't want anyone
know sheesh can't have anyone haha it
was a bunch who the ballroom let me just
oh yeah I open I'm so strong I just rip
it right off its hinges
ma'am yeah said Secret Service Michael
Scarn huh generators huh boom Oh us is
supposed to be locked
what does that even mean I practically
blew the door off their hinges and every
other one what is this gonna do now boom
oh come on
boom ah umm I'm sad now is this the
Seger's our Christmas card stops
printing in place and answers in part
you also do that how dare you how dare
all of you I'll have you arrested as
soon as I can come up with a reason to
arrest you another one no that was a
loud key card I was some cool I wonder
what door this unlocks hmm it's a card
in the shape of a keyhole because I'm
pretty sure there's no power in this
place otherwise it would be very awkward
I really don't mean to be harsh you know
I don't want to be harsh because this is
probably someone's like first attempt at
a game and I hate to be overly critical
boom singer detective Michael Karn
anybody here Hey hmm is there any
terrorist activities going on in these
quarters you tell me right you tell the
secret service of your terrorist illicit
activities hey buddy you want to admit
their crimes
no I need to get my act together because
I can't hi Kayla boom [ __ ] Jared Mike
again
Oh generator huh a generator from Tim
Horton Tim TomTom North Tim Tim Tim Tim
Burton Tim Burton not boom I shouldn't
play games that I'm sick the most
amazing thing is after this I plan to
try five nights at freddys 1020 mode
this is gonna be me doing a bunch of all
what did I do didn't do a damn thing
there's no extra lights on
I got generator one online oh okay great
okay so where am I supposed to go next
I already inspected the American beds
they were very patriotic I would have
taken a nap but duty calls every
American born with a handgun in a Bible
needs to know that America needs
defending well god damn it yeah Jim
whatever your name is I don't even know
I'm ever right a stability I'm gonna
game over I am officially unstable God
movies Oh
okay so that was courage this was an
indie or game you can thank y'all Minaj
for the recommendation he's a cool dude
but god damn it's been a while since I
played a thoroughly bad horror game to
the developer keep trying just remember
there's a whole lot of advice out there
on making a good horror game this is a
good first attempt obviously these are
free games so no one paid any money for
this but just hey keep trying man you're
doing great thank you so much for
watching check out the other scary games
that I played I played like 180 on by
now
description annotation things again
and as always I'll see you
really should be happy fun times but
it's not is it
I'm just too aggravated I'm too out of
my mind just he's calm I want to be able
to take them seriously Oh black bars
huge everybody look at our big red black
bar is nothing nothing innuendo II about
that